if you want to have massive success as
an entrepreneur then the first thing you
need to focus on is getting beyond the
survival point so you don't have to
worry about going back working for
somebody else getting the job that you
hate in order to put food on the table
and pay your bills
something like 80 of new businesses fail
within the first five years and that's
unacceptable that's crazy high it
doesn't have to be that way and the big
challenge here is most people don't get
to the point where they have enough
money coming in that they can support
themselves and so i want you to have the
big goal i want you to have the big
vision i want you to change the world i
want you to be a multi-millionaire i
want you to have a lasting impact and
contribution to people around you and
for that to happen you have to be around
so i don't want you only focusing on the
big picture and then having a close-up
shop in three to six months and go back
working for somebody else hating your
job and wishing you could still do what
you were doing before with your own
business to make that happen you have to
think big but act small and so there's
nothing wrong with starting on the side
starting part-time weekends evenings
start with a service instead of a
product to keep your costs down start
small get cash flow coming in get to the
point where you're making enough money
just to support yourself and you don't
have to worry about going back and get
another job and then that gives you the
platform to expand for massive success
keep that big picture in mind because
that's what motivates you to get up
every day and keep going you know it's
tough as an entrepreneur i remember you
know for me even now sometimes it's hard
waking up every morning and wanting to
go out and do what i do and it helps
having that big picture in mind you have
to keep that forefront but what you do
today and what you do tomorrow are the
small steps that get you going there so
if you're just starting up if you're if
you're not you know achieving success
yet or the success that you want to
achieve yet think about how do i get
beyond survival point and all those
little steps that will get you there and
once you get there you keep that big
picture in mind and gives you the
platform to go off and achieve all the
goals that you're going after whether
it's be a multi-millionaire change the
world have a huge impact on your
industry i want that for you and it's
entirely possible for you and i want you
to believe that and those small steps
they may be discouraging you feel like
you haven't done much today but those
small steps if you look back on it will
lead to bigger and bigger and bigger
steps so keep going keep that momentum
happening get beyond a survival stage
and you're you're on your way to
building a lasting legacy